what does that look like we're taking
tastes like brains
which looks questions
today we're trying sambhu cappuccinos I
personally love the idea of all these
crazy frappuccinos hopefully it's not
too scary
I actually prefer Starbucks over local
coffee places I almost broke down and
got the unicorn one what made you like
compelled to try the color zombie time
[Music]
what like a work of rares it does look
like Frankenstein it's like Hoffa
unicorn than half of disgusting dippin
oh my god it looks like a sculpture it's
not scary it's more cute I see purple
I'm like ooh this is gonna be grape
flavored but it's just whipped right I
think that's blueberry oh that's like
blueberry
I taste banana in this is my choice are
you happy it doesn't make me think
zombie though mm-hmm when I see this
basically think of like berries
especially not that sweet to me I like
the combination of all the flavors
mm-hmm it's very random though because
the top tastes totally different from
the inside I get a little bit of green
apple with some caramel and then a nod
like hint of chocolate this is good for
like like a birthday party there's
someone who really likes terrified it's
like Kiwis right there were like 12
flavors except it's taste like a caramel
apple if that's what it's supposed to be
it's pretty accurate I mean I taste
banana still I don't taste apples at all
I would much rather just have coffee and
have some Froyo seperating keep
incorporating fruit maybe there's some
kale in there next time no that's too
much like you're drinking three
different Starbucks drinks mm-hm
I'd be so terrified of the amount of
calories there in this do we have our
daily value of sugar just drinking it
from here to here yeah this is like a
week's worth of sugar yeah just don't
know if I could like walk into a place
and if you'd like I can order this and
then walk out like a normal person I
want to see like a vampire one which is
just completely red maybe with like
black whipped cream on top
that would be so cool Santa one won't
taste like a guy that touches kids I
would like to see a Griffin it's not
associated with a holiday but it's very
cool
did you put this in an oven will be
coming let's try it